hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play the lost souls
now this is actually an older game I
think was made back in 2011 not that
that's terribly old but considering
compared to me I'm extremely old so I've
heard that it's quite scary and I just
saw recently that it had an update at
least in the OS version I'm not sure so
let's give this a try that is loud
chapter 1 the beginning as per usual we
will start at the beginning wake up wake
up now this is made on the Unity engine
but it's also on a website called
congregate which if you didn't know
who's a website that has mostly flash
games there is no more time time for why
time to play time to go have fun in my
happy fun cell the door looks fragile
locked something is happening with the
door I'm free wow that was the easiest
jail escape I've ever had in my life I
can't move though it's damn dark I
should find some light how about this
it's too hot to unlock the iron support
Oh random strange noises playing in the
distance let's turn the volume back up
because they turned it down for the main
menu which was very loud but hopefully
you guys okay so this isn't lit so do i
light it with this one did I get it okay
I got it yeah I'm on a roll today I'm
doing fantastically okay so we got a
series of things here hi no need to be
doing The Scream seems very painful I
wonder what would happen if I got study
in this chair um you get tortured okay
so there's some stuff
some noises going on here hello locked
is it another bash down door guy just
push it until it opens here apparently
not okay
I'm mining cuz this is old style so I'm
counting on there being like tons of
jump scares and random things just
popping out of me out of nowhere I mean
it is it is still a web horror game so
do we got here we're looking for a key
I'm guessing I don't even know if I have
an inventory system I don't see anything
here not on the table not under the
table still not sure what that noise is
all about but I'll try to find wait
something done here some don't AHA got
ya can I crouch no apparently not
something is I but I can't reach it I
can't reach that shut up I'm screaming -
out of frustration there's something
here I can use to get it now I can pick
that up that's fantastic get it get it
get it good yeah it worked just fine I'm
holding an item alright press space to
release a night
oh that's cool okay so I got the key
something is written run and never look
behind food Wahhabi Ozai that's what run
never look behind okay who's behind me
oh I expected to be back there you gotta
be joking me that's not cool
ah oh it's just that's not fair
alright okay let's do this quickly again
I'm free okay let me go let me go let me
go let me go let me go let me go I know
how to get this I know how to do this
hahaha I didn't think alright I'm done
okay so I gotta get the key can I do I
need to look at this before I can get
that I can't reach it let's grab this
and this time when we go through here we
will just run ah
there's
a girl behind me or something I don't
know is like a woman some lady I'm
trying to jump me again I know I'm
irresistible even to the monster ladies
they all want a piece of markiplier I
know oh I know
hello can I go through loading uh-oh
you'll be loading what god oh hello room
okay no need for me to do anything here
I found a key cool kind of not cool
based on what I'm seeing in here but if
someone scatting over there shabba-doo
ba'da pow what sounds like hello do I
still need to run and never look back
is that what I need to do I don't like
this place how to hello hello hello
alright I have a key ok there's a new
key ok so I'm assuming of those no honey
no mommy good
was that a doom sound effect that
sounded like it would it's some kind of
energy is it an energy drink does it
have what plants crave I see where I
hear someone beatboxing over there oh
here we go okay got this go down this
hallway go over here find some living
room what wha where's that hello
Scoob - Babu BAP - Scoob duped Bhau
okay what what which was the solid green
that doesn't make any sense at all okay
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna drop that
pick up the fuse go down to the basement
worth I I like this place I'm gonna say
that right now I don't like this place
much at all I don't like many of the
places i go to but i mean they could
throw off them decorations on the walls
beat hey look at that
did it drive the demons away I don't
hear the beatboxing anymore demonic lady
beatboxing that make a great metal band
wouldn't that just be the best metal
band name demonic lady beatboxing you
can make that band but give me a nickel
every time you play a song hello I
didn't understand
yeah that's much better okay I died
before completing my ritual of exorcism
the ghosts just killed me and now I'm
part of this freaking house if someone
is reading this complete the rituals
leave as soon as possible I mean some
horrible things to finish it I cut some
people in pieces the ritual needs all
senses of human to bring the life
feeling to these ghosts when you unlock
this door you'll take the responsibility
okay there's this the key to the ritual
door or something I mean that other key
hello oh hi that's not good
it's a kid oh that's horrible he's still
alive okay the pedestals are the support
for the body parts and all the energy is
going to be sealed from the house what
what I know oh no oh no where'd that
door come from this was not here before
hello hello oh all right
bring it on you got well fingers oh my
god
finger it's so terrifying okay see
tongue goes here foot their ears kid
okay just calm down we feel it is in the
air was that enough a nose was that nose
okay that one was a little confusing
good this is so weird why do I need to
do this why is this necessary hey you
son of [ __ ] you go away I don't want to
deal with you here's another
yeah I stopped it what's what's all this
weirdness hey kid what you doing there
what do you want doing
you're all so weird what is hi lady are
you Lou you're looking at me agent that
is disconcerting calm the baby comedy
boob ha ha why I was helping your baby
oh just helping your baby give it a toy
make it stop crying am i dead oh come on
am i dead damn it oh that's dumb I was
trying to calm the baby
maybe I touched her baby and she really
didn't like me touching it oh I do not
like this game it's so weird it's so oh
come on
I forgot I gotta get the key look drop
that on the ground then I threw it on
the ground Shiva Shiva Shiva you pie at
least I got the lady beatbox you're back
in here my life it really calms me down
in these tiring or wrong situations okay
anyway just need to get down here then
we'll get right back up we'll get the
finger in the ear or nose or whatever
the hell it was I don't know where okay
lady beatboxer please go away what
happens if I don't accept the
responsibility why can't I just why
can't I just leave oh yeah cuz the
energy is blocking my way that's right
okay
see these people hello how are y'all
kitty
no you doing good let's drop this key so
I can pick up the nose here nothing
weird about what I'm doing why why are
you looking at me so funny there's
something in the trashcan no just like
that okay get to finger got the nose got
the finger in the nose with the finger
into over here miss RIE finger nose
finger to the nose oh what's that is
that something over there
we got a tongue just lying around goody
goody gumdrops those over there okay hi
again how are you you good good let's
see the woman will always protect her
baby the baby hates the darkness I don't
think it's a good idea to go inside when
she's in there in there you're in the
okay go away close the damn door girl
what is wrong with you okay I'm not
gonna go anywhere near that I'm gonna go
try and find the other part what with
the noises I'm Harry
well maybe that's the only place I can
go cuz it doesn't seem to be I hear
strange noises in my ear
okay all right so the baby doesn't like
the darkness but now it's all bright and
sunshiny I just can't stop it with the
doom noises it's all bright and sunshiny
now but I don't really need high you're
still disturbing okay don't laugh at me
don't mock me incessantly I know what
I'm doing here or I do not or I don't
know him
hi excuse me I'm trying to do something
here okay so the lights are flickering
I'm gonna get out of here I'm not going
near you here you want toy you want toy
little boy you want toys for boys toy
there's no other body parts that I can
get this is silliness this is just
silliness unless another plague war has
Bond randomly I have this key over here
but I don't know what it goes to just a
whole bunch of weird noises happening
and nothing to it the only threat is a
lady in that room cuz of her baby hey
man how's that baby doing hey man Bera
how's that baby doing okay let me just
try to put it on her this little there
we go
bingo long delay yes I'm a genius oh
goody goody gumdrops I got an ear didn't
I get in here no I get a tongue that's
right I got a nose tongue and finger day
I'm a so smart maybe the house is losing
power okay so maybe one of the areas has
unlocked which means that I can move
forward yes please yes all right cool
beans boo
all this isn't good this isn't a good
thing
Oh is there a delicacy under this thingy
hi
nice breakdancing there that's not what
I thought I was gonna get but he's
that's something Hyuk and I thank you
today can you turn the light back on and
turn off the hell ambience
you've got they don't appreciate it oh
here's a nice breakdancing man you've
really been trying practicing that is
phenomenal
you could fly in the other amnesia Gus
and Torian here you can breakdance it's
amazing good job you're gonna go far kid
I love the at the real moaning Aang Aang
Aang Aang Aang Aang Aang Aang Aang Aang
all right let's just get this done
Boop maybe I can leave now or maybe
you'll never leave how about that okay
um wait where do I go now where do I go
now what do I do
how do I get into here I'm gonna lock
seems to be a high scanner seems like
it's off what what what oh why you
closed
it's the baby Kenny sans stop it kid
geez oh man uh hang on let me use this
key this was the second key I got but I
never used it on anything did I I don't
know if I used it on anything I may have
used it to open the door but I don't
know what else I could possibly do no
not there we check inside because of I
hope that lady is not there lady how's
your baby how's that bleh we doing okay
no baby my little girls just hanging
there and the other kids hanging out
over there
hi dad open still no what I need to do I
go back there is no need to go back okay
can I turn the lights on maybe maybe oh
look the fuse got popped out oh okay oh
good the hellish nightmare is now over
oh no the moaning is too high kid you're
gonna go far kid you're gonna be a star
someday just keep it up keep the
creepiness up all right let's see if we
can go through here now can I get out
here with my eye or do I need I need
that eyeball
do I need to get the other eye from the
corpse or can I just grab this I know I
need the other eye of course why would I
would I be able to use the same eye all
right
why these doors keep closing when I get
near to him hey I want to see the brick
dance and chair
get out of there hey what are you doing
that's what I thought okay so now I come
over here how nobody can I have your
other eye oh well what the hell I don't
know what I'm supposed to do I do here
kid come here come here
go I'm not looking I'm not looking a
wolf I you're closer than I thought
you'd be
shove your eye into there shove it in
there to shove your ghostly eye in
Oh
ah come on I tried that before what the
hell
alright welcome back guys I just I had
an idea that I was clicking on the
pedestal and not the eye itself and
apparently whoop okay that was it okay
so let's move on it work
hooray hello kid open please and let me
go home
thank you she's gonna carry this eye
with me as I wander out into the world
people are gonna see me on the street
with an eyeball hello kid
slam it shut what I'm flying now well
how's it uh I thought I thought those me
about to shut the door and then all
sudden I I could foot and fly up into
the sky like a little birdie okay that
last part took way longer than it should
have ah happy
I cut job out but you guys didn't see me
wandering us cuz I thought I'd click the
I already and I was like oh take the I
those like my first time it was like
apparently I dog crap okay so anyway
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos hit I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye
Oh